HAVE TO DO A LITTLE ASS
COVERING.
SO LET'S POP THIS UP.
OKAY?
( LAUGHTER )
JUST COVERING MY ASS.
COVERING MY ASS.
AND LEASE-- YOU KNOW WHAT?
LET'S HAVE SOMEONE FROM COMEDY
CENTRAL LEGAL COME OUT AND STAND
OVER MY SHOULDER, IF YOU COULD,
COMEDY CENTRAL THERE.
THANK YOU.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
YOU KNOW WHAT WE OUGHT TO DO?
THIS IS KIND OF DANGEROUS, SO WE
SHOULD FLASH THE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS OF THIS BIT BEFORE WE
START.
GOOD.
IT'S TRUE.
I REALLY-- THAT LAST ONE I
REALLY BELIEVE THAT LAST
PARAGRAPH.
OK GREAT.
RESUME COMEDY BIT.
NOW, LOOK, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
YOU GUYS, BUT I GOT SOME MESSAGE
FROM BALTIMORE LOUD AND CLEAR.
ONLY WAY WE HAVE A CHANCE OF
GETTING COPS CHARGED IN TAMIR
RICE'S BORDER IS A CLONE ARMY OF
MARILYN MOSBYS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
I'M JUST SAYING, THIS FAMILY
NEEDS JUSTICE, AND THE
AUTHORITIES WILL DO EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO COVER UP THEIR OWN
LIKE-- I'M SURE THE AUTHORITIES
ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
BRING ABOUT A RESOLUTION.
( LAUGHTER )
BUT IT MIGHT BE TIME TO REMIND
THEM THAT THEY'VE HAD PLENTY OF
TIME TO BRING CHARGES, OKAY.
THE THING WE HAVE TO KEEP
HAMMERING HOME, YOU GUYS, IS NO
JUSTICE, NO PEACE.
I'M NOT NECESSARILY SAYING--
LOOK, LET ME PUT IT LIKE THIS.
IF WE WANT TO GET JUSTICE HERE,
WE HAVE TO GET LOUD-- WHAT,
WHAT, WHAT?
, OF COURSE.
JUSTICE AND PEACE, OF COURSE,
THEY'RE NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE.
( LAUGHTER )
THE ONLY WAY ANYONE LISTENS IS
IF THE FIGHT SPILLS OUT INTO THE
STREETS Y'ALL, YOU BE WHAT I'M.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
WHAT?
OR, OR, OR IF YOU'D RATHER, FEEL
FREE TO PROTEST INSIDE YOUR
HOME.
( LAUGHTER )
START A HASHTAG?
SEND A STRONGLY WORDED E-MAIL TO
YOUR LOCAL REPRESENTATIVE.
VIOLENCE IS NEVER THE ANSWER.
OKAY.
( LAUGHTER )
BUT PEOPLE NEED TO GET THER
VOICES HEARD SOMEHOW.
AND, LOOK, MAYBE SOMETIMES THAT
TAKES THE FORM OF ANGER.
AND YOU KNOW, WHEN THAT ANGER--
WHAT!
OKAY, HOW'S THIS?
THAT FAMILY NEEDS JUSTICE AND WE
CANNOT LET THAT STORY FADE AWAY.
IS THAT OKAY?
ALL RIGHT LET ME PUT IT LIKE
THIS.
MARILYN MOSBY MAY HAVE BROUGHT
CHARGES AGAINST THOSE COPS IN
BALTIMORE.
SOME SAY SHE MAY HAVE ACTED TOO
SWIFTLY.
THE DETAILS ARE STILL COMING OUT
AS OF THIS MOMENT BUT IT
DIDN'T SEEM LIKE ANYTHING
HAPPENED UNTIL PEOPLE GOT OUT ON
THE STREETS.
IT SHOULD NOT BE THIS WAY BUT
IT'S NOT SURPRISING.
THE MESSAGE WE'RE STILL GETTING
IS NOBODY PAYS ATTENTION UNTIL
YOU GET A LITTLE ANGRY.
WELL, I'M ANGRY AS HELL ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED TO TAMIR RICE.